so we're bringing back after popular man
cats in the wild evidently Theo has been
at a rave
drugs up hoes down good detail left is
the DJ booth to [ __ ] dance with the
people there's intense and there's not
that many people there yeah that clubs
like that cuz college up some others
College later than Marty in the stew
yeah like in the convention and we're
all the college things they would have
come see this guy do magic know some
guy's wife is leaving him memory clubs
they had on college campuses every club
you ever [ __ ] imagine they get
together it'll be like four of them hmm
last week we talked about how much
Brendon loved Jerry Springer and that's
why he one day fulfilled his dream and
he was on dr. Phil Starbucks coffee bean
is get my eyelashes done eyebrows make
sure I'm put together I'm on point
hmm what it takes to that and og
baddam whose lifestyle that I have I
will steal for my family and me since I
was a baby so I kind of still expect
that at 26 I do go shopping on my own
but like I said if I could some of my
mom's money before my money than I will
in the past three years I've probably
stolen about twenty to twenty-five
thousand dollars from my mom I've stolen
between three to five thousand from my
sister when I steal I get a rush this
one time I stole from my friend she was
at work at the time and she would leave
her cash at home she would literally
have like three or four granddaughters I
just find the cash out of the purse if I
can take somebody else's money to build
myself up then I'm going to I have to
have the money to make myself look as a
burglar do what I like to post for a guy
I know I am a good worker I got a little
bit of an ass so it's like let me show
what guys gave me it's four minutes of
this Barney so how did conclude decide
to stop stealing no he didn't dude we
don't have the same not well this is
still going on this it was that was
Hollywood where he was down in we need
to send one this got a one Allison
change concert you know yeah that'd be
great
even amount know I filmed Nine Inch
Nails concert bro he's stealing yeah
that's my world right there mosh pits
your big ass in mosh pits oh yeah kids
we're down who were you were you that
battering ram or you were you more the
referee and taking care of kids yeah I
take care of everybody line side like
that movie The Blind Side yeah I got
sucked in a job by 15 year old
that [ __ ] hurt why'd he punch you it
would be just mashing is that a penny
wise console ooh we were just like it
was a big ass circle pit what was the
song girl in what song were they playing
at the time he was [ __ ] thority oh
yeah that'll do it man they thought I
was Authority I just damn yeah ya know
where D Wilson or something Authority
and chin he's been moonlighting on the
side behind her backs
[Laughter]
[Music]
skeletons don't do something we can't
hear it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
behind the table ring oh yeah
kimchi right this likes of your
ownership
this was two weeks ago in Big Bear yeah
there's a small bass on the bass again
the bass isn't really playing all they
need is you should fell out front ma I'd
do it damn that guy's terrible huh well
this is socialism man what kind of agent
are they huh
you look Filipino they look yeah yeah
but it could be something else and
Filipinos really love to get up there on
the microphone okay oh yeah and what is
it about that Asia now what Asian
culture likes to get up on the
microphone the most no this is something
our Koreans know there's a ton of Craner
entertainers but I don't know if they
like like it the most no know what I
think karaoke the first thing I think of
is you know for them but as far as like
talent goes bright Korea right Koreans
and Filipinos I think yeah well as far
as musical time singing yeah yeah
and we actually someone found a picture
of Chappelle at homecoming she let's me
let me guess her name I loved oh yeah is
it Beth no Tiffany no Stephanie no Kimmy
no kami Kelly no Rachel no Monica I
think her name starts with a L Lauren no
well arrest Lisa no Linda I thought
you'd rather say right there Linda
the Lin's be Leslie Lin Lindsay Lindsay
the lesbian that was first dance that's
like first and like there you all up on
that bro that backhand right looks like
he he hasn't made up his mind whether he
wants to guess we should bring in some
dance of some of my pictures when we
went to dances yeah sure my mom and dad
yeah you got to get a few I got some
yeah dan where did somebody find this
she said it to me
wow that's like a while a girl well they
used to hook me up I was always the guy
who got hooked up with the friend that
didn't have a date you know okay
lesbians because they figured you got to
hit it off it was anybody they're like
oh we'll hook them up with the big big
Samantha or something or you know your
likes at all
yeah lo Becca or something yeah a little
risky you know Ramona little rusty
Ramona get a little Ronny all right no
Ronnie's bored
yeah so I don't always get the date I
always be like that ninth wheel yeah you
know that service that uh you know that
small time and what's lesbian Linda do
these days listen it's Linda what'd she
do huh dude teacher that's cool yeah
she's Dan you think I'd act like a ton
of people fries do ya do you yeah man
not a lot of not a lot of I do it I
don't know
hell yeah do you Nick uh when I go back
home I see them but it's like we're not
talking daily do I look like Jacob
Hester he played football for a while
LSU fall back pull them up that's what
you look like
I think so
yeah he's a stud
if you got in trouble though right no he
didn't
no he's a good man who the mauler the
Chargers right yeah you got to get his
helmet off him nothing there you go no
you look like huh
you look like you know yeah you're right
with this you don't think right now hold
on oh hell yeah boy he's a stud
praise God I look like number 57 over
there Helen oh wow damn that is you huh
[Music]
the King nothing
[Music]